madame la Présidente de la Commission
d'affaires sociales madame la rapporteur
général mesdames et messieurs monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers collègues
déposez une motion référendaire
s'inscrirait dans une stratégie je cite
à combattre sans obstruer
stratégie ou stratagème nous sommes en
droit de nous interroger en effet les
auteurs de la motion crient au scandale
pour la logement de l'âge de la route de
l'ouverture des droits à 64 ans en
disant que l'on pousse les Français à
travailler plus longtemps mais n'est-ce
pas mes chers collègues la réforme
Touraine qui prévoit une durée de
cotisation de 172 trimestres soit 43 ans
pour bénéficier d'une retraite à taux
plein or la moyenne d'âge d'entraide sur
le marché du travail est de 22 ans et si
je compte bien 22 + 43 ça fait 65
alors vous allez me répondre que les
Français peuvent toujours partir à 60
ans oui mais avec quelle retraite
n'ayant pas une retraite à taux plein
leur pension subira une décote
c'est une machine en fait à créer des
retraités plus pauvres et nous ne le
voulons pas
invoquer le référendum pour donner la
parole au peuple sur un sujet qu'il
concerne directement
témoignerait témoignerait d'une volonté
démocratique affirmée
tel est le synopsis mais qu'en est-il
vraiment monsieur le Président Kader
pourquoi déposer une motion référendaire
dont les chances d'aboutir semblent bien
mince
pourquoi déposer une telle motion qui si
elle devait aller à son terme
reviendrait à dessaisir le Parlement de
son pouvoir de débattre de son pouvoir
d'amender et donc de son pouvoir
d'améliorer un texte particulièrement
important en effet à travers le prisme
de la retraite nous parlons de travail
nous parlons d'égalité homme-femme nous
parlons de justice sociale nous parlons
de santé sujet qui m'est cher nous
parlons de vieillissement c'est donc un
projet de société qui soustend ce texte
et il serait illusoire et bien naïf de
penser qu'un référendum permettrait de
répondre aux différents enjeux de la
réforme des retraites
au nom d'un retour à une légitimité
populaire exprimée vient un instrument
de démocratie directe la proposition de
recourir au référendum revient à
empêcher tout débat au fond
pour être pertinent et exprimer une
réelle volonté populaire le référendum
d'importer sur des questions claires
précises concise et limitée la
complexité des situations liées à la
retraite permettent de répondre à ses
exigences ne risque-t-il pas de se muer
en plébiscite entraînant une
personnalisation extrême du débat
masquant les enjeux et cristallisant les
tensions d'une société fracturée
vous me permettrez de reprendre les
propos du professeur de microso le
microusseau qui lui-même a déjà été cité
hier par notre collègue Eliane assassin
je cite Dominique Rousseau la démocratie
a besoin d'institutions intermédiaire
pour fonctionner sereinement et éviter
une personnalisation excessive du
pouvoir je cite encore le référendum
laisse penser que ces institutions sont
un obstacle à la démocratie
alors qu'elles sont précisément les
instruments qui font passer de la
barbarie à la civilisation fin de
citation c'est pourquoi c'est pourquoi
je m'interroge sur cette volonté de
s'auto mutiler
après des débats affligents à
l'Assemblée nationale tout le monde l'a
dit qui ont encore davantage assombri
l'image des parlementaires et creuser le
fossé entre élu et citoyen il est
particulièrement important voir vital
pour la démocraties représentative
d'assumer notre mission d'exprimer
clairement nos positions et de défendre
nos opinions les syndicats ont de ce
point de vue jusqu'à ce jour fait preuve
de responsabilité en jouant leur rôle
les élus politiques
serait-il moins capables que les élus
professionnels de remplir les
obligations de leur mandat je pose la
question je souhaite j'espère et je suis
persuadé que tous ensemble dans cette
hémicycle nous saurons avec
détermination conviction faire évoluer
ce texte monsieur le ministre cette
réforme n'est peut-être pas proposée au
bon moment il aurait fallu que le
gouvernement prenne en compte les
propositions du Sénat beaucoup plus tôt
en effet depuis 2019 depuis 2019 la
commission d'affaires du affaires
sociales du Sénat recommande l'adoption
de la réforme paramétrique des retraites
afin de préserver la soutenabilité
financière du système et donc sa
pérennité pour les générations futures
Serge René Paul nous devons agir pour ne
pas laisser filer le déficit je vous
rappelle plus de 150 milliards d'euros
cumulés pour les 10 prochaines années et
ses prévisions sont très optimistes
puisque basées sur un taux de chômage à
4,5%. cette réforme est donc urgente
proposée par la majorité sénatoriale
depuis plusieurs années le report de la
génial et l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation vont enfin être mise en
oeuvre mais si nous partageons la
philosophie globale du projet pour
garantir la pérennité de notre système
nous avons fait de nombreuses
propositions pour amél la situation des
Françaises et des Français en
particulier celle des seniors celle des
mers de famille celles des enfants
orphelins et celles du handicap faudra
relire le texte vous vous révérez que
c'est vrai si vous dit c'est pas vrai
c'est parce que vous n'avez pas lu nous
souhaitons également promouvoir un
système plus équitable notamment à
travers la lutte contre la fraude et la
participation de tous les salariés à
l'effort de travailler plus nous aurons
l'occasion mes chers collègues d'y
revenir en détail au cours de l'examen
des articles et des discussions mes
chers collègues nous ne pouvons renoncer
à nous prononcer sur ce texte nous ne
pouvons pas nous défausser c'est pour
toutes ces raisons que le groupe LR ne
votera pas cette motion et que nous
consacrerons le temps imparti à un débat
argumenté en nous appuyant sur le
travail considérable réalisé par nos
rapporteurs je vous remercie
[Musique]